별거 아닌 이야기도 정말 재밌게 말하는 사람이 있지 않나요?
내가 말했으면 그냥 노잼이었을 텐데 말이에요
이번 5분 레벨업에서는
국언의 참고사를 바탕으로
언제나 어디서나 매력적인 말 재밌게 하는 사람의 특징
두 가지를 알려드릴게요
첫 번째, 묘사, 화법
내가 직접 겪었을 땐 분명 임팩트 있는 에피소드였는데
그걸 다른 사람한테 썰 풀면
그냥 노잼 스토리가 되지 않나요?
그래서 그럴 때마다
아, 이건 진짜 너가 그 자리에 있었으면 대박인 건데
라며?
괜히 머쓱해지곤 하잖아요
나 진짜 무서운 얘기 하나 있는데
얘기해줄까?
무서운 얘기? 뭐, 뭔데?
아니, 내가 원래 예전부터 인적 드문 야산에서
혼자 캠핑하는 걸 좋아했거든
아니, 굳이 왜?
그야 낭만 개싹뒤지잖아
와, 개미친 놈 안 무섭냐?
좀 무섭긴 한데
그래도 평소에 코코랑 같이 다니니까
그렇게 막 무섭진 않았거든
코코가 누군데?
우리 집 개, 암튼 그날도
썰 푸는데 몰입도도 떨어지고
그냥 재미없게 말하는 사람의 가장 큰 특징은
재미없게 썰 푸는 사람의 특징은
1인칭 시점으로만 이야기를 풀어간다는 겁니다
인간은 누구나 1인칭 시점으로 살아갑니다
그렇기에 내가 겪었던 경험담 또한 모두
1인칭 시점으로 기억하는 게 당연한 거죠
하지만 떠오르는 대로
계속 1인칭 시점으로만 썰을 풀고
그러면 전달력과 몰입도는
떨어질 수밖에 없습니다
왜냐하면
계속 나한테 혼자 왔냐고 묻는 거야
그러다 결국 조용해지긴 했는데
그래도 뭔가 겁나 이상하잖아
듣는 사람 입장에선
머릿속으로 그림이 그려지지 않거든요
그러니 몰입도가 떨어져
지루해질 수밖에 없는 거죠
하지만 이완 반대로
갑자기 텐트 밖에서 사람 목소리가 들리더라고
자신의 경험담을 보다 더 흥미롭게 이야기하고 싶다면
그래서 내가 누구냐고 물으니까
지금 혼자 계세요?
그래서 내가
네? 그 그런데요? 왜요?
라고 했는데 계속
지금 혼자 계세요?
이 말만 계속 반복하는 거야
마치 상황극을 하듯
1인 다역으로 묘사해주는 것이 좋습니다
왜냐하면
그러다 결국 조용해지긴 했는데
그래도 겁나 이상하잖아
그래서 난 개쫄려가지고 바로 코코 껴안았는데
코코는 또 신났는지 계속 내 얼굴을 핥더라고
암튼 그렇게 잠설치다가 해뜨자마자
정신없이 짐 챙겨서 집으로 왔거든
자신의 경험담을 1인칭 시점으로 풀어가다가
중간중간
근데 집 오니까 엄마가
뭐야? 코코 안 데려왔어?
이야기 속 등장하는 인물들의 말을
직접 묘사해주는 것만으로도
장면이 눈앞에 실제로 일어나는 것처럼 전개되어
몰입도가 비교도 안 되게 높아지거든요
와시 코코 산에 두고 왔구나
개졌댔다 생각하고 있었는데
엄마가 또 이렇게 말하시더라고
뭐야 뭘 이렇게 당황하니?
얼른 동물병원 가서 데려와
아 맞네 어제 코코 진료 본다고
나 혼자 캠핑 갔었지 생각드는데
와시 그 순간 진짜 다행이네 싶더라고
뭐야 그럼 텐트에서 핥은 건 누구야?
어?
두 번째 신이 피한 vs 신이 피해
듣는 순간 머릿속으로 그림이 그려지면서
와 이 사람 진짜 생동감 있게 말 잘하네
라고 생각들게 만드는 사람의 비밀이 뭔지 아시나요?
그 근데 생각해보면
이거 그냥 왕대가 강아지 귀신한테 추행당한 썰 아니야?
와 그러네 왕대 이 새끼 강아지 귀신한테 개당했네?
어? 개의 반대?
어 뭐야 그렇게 생각하니까 지 진짜 하나도 안 무섭네
근데 있잖아 그때 내 얼굴을 핥은 그것이
어쩌면 강아지 귀신이 아닐 수도 있어
그 그럼 뭔데?
아 아니 아침에 일어나 보니까 텐트 주변에 버려진 유기견들이 있더라고?
걔네들이 들어와서 핥은 거일 수도 있지 뭐
듣는 순간 머릿속으로 그림이 그려질 정도로
생동감 있게 말하는 사람과 그러지 못하는 사람의 차이는
유기견? 불쌍하다 그래서 어떻게 했어?
뭘 어떡하긴 바로 집으로 존나 튀었지
말의 디테일입니다
근데 언어학의 아버지 페르디낭 드 소시르는
시니피앙과 시니피에라는 언어학 개념을 정의했는데요
시니피앙은 문자 그 자체를 의미합니다
그리고 그 문자를 보고 상상하는 이미지가 바로 시니피에죠
예를 들어 개는 한국어로는 개 영어로는 도그
일본어로는 인우라는 사전적 의미가 명확하게 있습니다
하지만 개를 상상하는 이미지는 사람마다 모두 다릅니다
누군가는 사나운 맹견을 떠올릴 수 있고
또 다른 누군가는 귀여운 댕댕이를 떠올릴 수 있습니다
그렇기에 말의 전달력을 높여
상대방에게 보다 더 생생한 이미지를 전해주고 싶다면
상황 묘사를 포괄적으로 하기보다는
최대한 디테일하게 묘사해주는 것이 좋습니다
왜냐하면
그날 코코를 안 데려간 게 진짜 천만다행이지
오 뭐야 코코부터 걱정하는 거야?
아 아니 걔네들이 다칠까 봐
우리 코코가 또 한 성격 하거든
에이 코코가 성격이 있어봤자 뭐 얼마나 이...
아니야 코코부터 걱정하는 거야
흠뻑 치면 진짜 큰일 날걸
사람들은 생각보다 생각하는 게 전부 다르거든요
와 이... 이분이... 아니 얘가 코코라고?
와스벌 이 정도면 강아지 귀신도 존댈 뻔했겠는데?
5분 안에 레벨업 비치키를 구독하시고
실전 자기개발 버프를 받아가세요